of the world's eight largest economies
five command nuclear weapons the united
states united kingdom china india and
france
another two germany and italy host
american nuclear weapons only one the
third largest has neither built nor
borrowed them
japan
but japan doesn't just object to nuclear
war
among east asian countries only taiwan
employs fewer active troops though just
marginally and yet with one-fifth the
population
when you include reserve and
paramilitary members japan's armed
forces are nearly six times smaller than
the next closest east asian country
of course number of troops is but one
component of defense and no single
figure can possibly capture the overall
strength of a nation
japan is certainly not weak by global
standards
its neighbors however are exceptionally
strong and its region especially
precarious
this bar represents the total defense
expenditure in east asia from 1994 to
the present
during the 90s japan alone commanded
nearly 40 percent of the pie
then for all but one of the next 20
years its share declined until it ended
up at just 10.7 percent in 2019
the missing context you might argue is
china
add it to the mix and it may seem as
though japan's defense expenditure
hasn't so much fallen as china's has
exploded dwarfing all others by
comparison
but an even closer examination shows
that despite this increase russia and
south korea have managed to keep up
whereas japan has not
today the country finds itself a mere
stone's throw away from not one but
three nuclear powers
since 1958 its fighter jets have been
scrambled over 30 000 times a large and
increasing portion of which have
occurred in the last 20 years in
response to chinese and russian
incursions
and when north korea fired a ballistic
missile directly above a japanese island
home to 5 million people in 2017
many began to wonder
is japan's laudable devotion to pacifism
compatible with the challenges of the
21st century
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch the exclusive bonus
video which accompanies this one
the simplest measure of military
strength is expenditure
it stands to reason that the more a
nation spends the better prepared it's
likely to be for war
from this perspective japan seems quite
formidable especially when the two
outliers the us and china are excluded
it sits in the same league as germany
france and south korea
but there are a number of reasons
expenditure alone can be misleading and
that's perhaps never been more true than
in the case of japan
first the most important question is on
what does it spend
this is its 2021 defense budget
the single largest component 43 percent
is maintenance
this is a broad category that includes
everything from health care to education
and fuel
but roughly half this money is spent on
just one thing
repair
as the most earthquake prone country on
earth japan simply has more things to
fix
in 2011 the tohuku earthquake and
subsequent tsunami became the second
most costly natural disaster in recorded
history totaling somewhere between two
and three hundred billion us dollars
an estimated seven hundred thousand
buildings were at least partially
destroyed in the process
the third most expensive disaster
another earthquake also occurred in
japan 16 years earlier
because its defense budget is for the
most part fixed this leaves much less
room for everything else
research development and equipment
procurement each comprise less than four
percent of the overall budget
the second most important question when
it comes to defense spending is for how
much
here japan is at a severe disadvantage
in 1976 its prime minister banned the
sale of military hardware to any nation
under any circumstances as part of its
commitment to peace
that left japanese defense companies
with exactly one potential buyer and not
just any buyer but a defense company's
least favorite kind a staunch pacifist
while american contractors like lockheed
martin make nearly all their money from
defense of japan's 10 largest only 2
make more than 3 percent from it
why bend backwards trying to please one
very picky customer while tarnishing
one's reputation when there are millions
of enthusiastic consumer electronics
customers
banned from selling overseas its
companies devoted few resources to their
defense divisions
this disinterest in turn discouraged
investment from the government making
them even less competitive
for a country famous for manufacturing
its arms contractors have fared
remarkably poorly in international
rankings
japan in other words was forced to
either buy expensive equipment
domestically or import expensive
equipment from abroad making it even
more dependent on others in the process
after 40 years the export ban was
finally lifted in 2014
under the new rules sales are allowed so
long as their nature is purely defensive
and quote contribute to world peace
despite this japan lost to france in
2016 and just now the us in selling
submarines to australia
its lack of infrastructure meant it
could only promise one submarine a year
and while its first deal has since been
struck other countries will still have a
40-year head start
its equipment may have a reputation for
high quality but it also has one for
high prices
now earthquakes and overpriced equipment
are significant obstacles but they are
just obstacles given the requisite
effort political will and time japan
could in theory overcome them
unfortunately it faces another much
larger challenge
one for which no law could possibly fix
war requires soldiers
soldiers are made of humans and japan is
rapidly running out for a country to
maintain its population to neither grow
nor shrink the average woman needs to
have just slightly over two children in
her lifetime one to replace each parent
china fell below this replacement level
of fertility in 1991
russia in 89 and vietnam in 99.
the world average is trending downwards
which is to say most of the world is
aging
japan with a fertility rate of just 1.3
children per two adults is no exception
the only difference is that it began
this process way way earlier about 20
years before the rest of east asia
china's population decline is just
getting started but in the last 10 years
japan has already lost 1.5 million
people
during this decade it will lose another
8 million in the 2030s 10 million more
it doesn't just lack people it lacks the
right kind those young enough to fight
for the nation
by 2050 40
of the country will be aged over 65.
setting aside the economic consequences
this will bring first and foremost this
creates a simple problem of manpower
the broader labor shortage makes it
difficult for the government to compete
with the generous wages and benefits
offered by private employers
the country hasn't been able to find
enough soldiers since 2014.
in 2018 it was forced to lower its
standards increasing the maximum age for
new recruits from 26 to 32.
as a result the average age of its
soldiers is now 35 a full decade older
than the rest of east asia
even if these soldiers could make up for
youthful strength with wisdom or
experience they face a different kind of
problem
in short too many chiefs and not enough
indians most places in the world solve
this problem the same way
if too few people voluntarily sign up
the government will simply force them
conscription is widespread across east
asia
south korea takes a roughly 20-month
chunk out of the lives of its young men
until recently those in taiwan had to
put their lives on hold for around a
year
but political and cultural opposition
ensure the japanese armed forces will
never have this option
and while it's true that technology can
help supplement human forces military
strength is relative and its neighbors
will have no harder time acquiring or
developing new weapons and capabilities
in fact the opposite
in truth no one knows how prepared japan
is for conflict
not even japan
the very nature of war is such that an
outcome is never truly known until it
actually occurs
as a pacifist nation japan has no modern
data points on which to extrapolate
having never fired a bullet in combat
for 70 straight years and with
commanders who have never in their life
witnessed war first hand making
predictions is especially fraught
even its equipment remains untested
some mitsubishi-made tanks were found to
lack contingency space for injured
soldiers they had been designed built
and tested in sterile lab conditions far
removed from the battlefield
another reason its capabilities are
difficult to objectively assess is
deliberate obfuscation
officially japan has no aircraft
carriers which have an offensive
association
no instead it operates defensive
helicopter destroyers you be the judge
the nation's historical aggression
combined with its now long-standing
peaceful and neutral stance both
constrain its available options
behavior that might go unnoticed
elsewhere is met with great suspicion
thanks to its past
by keeping a low profile japan reassures
the rest of the world
yet by doing so even the smallest mole
hill of change is perceived by others as
a mountain
many including the current government of
japan believe any change incremental
enough to avoid attracting attention
from its neighbors would be by
definition insufficient to prepare the
country for conflict
indeed the 21st century has brought
several new challenges each of which
would be significant on its own
north korea's acquisition of nuclear
weapons china's attempted annexation of
japan's primary trade routes and
russia's general provocations
at the same time japan must overcome new
impediments like its shrinking
population
so why hasn't the third largest economy
devoted more money new laws or any other
measure for that matter to strengthen
its defenses
the ultimate answer has nothing at all
to do with its aging population lack of
combat experience or arms export law
the real reason is
next time in part two of japan's
pacifist paradox
but before we answer that question we
need to take a brief detour to talk
about why japan almost has nuclear
weapons a part 1.5 if you will
exclusively available on nebula where
you can watch bonus and extended videos
for just about every other video you see
on this channel
if you enjoyed this video you'd probably
like my nebula exclusive on why the
united states doesn't face the same
demographic challenges as china or japan
you might also like my video explaining
how corporations legally vote in hong
kong
nebula also has full-length originals
like legal eagles bad law words good or
tech alters technorama
sign up by clicking the link on screen
right now and for just 15 bucks a year
you also get access to curiosity stream
home to great documentaries like this
one on the history of afghanistan
you